welcome to Manchester we're at the heart
of the city at the University here
Oxford Road university place and this is
the sky stand up be countered Roadshow
we are launching it today it's out and
about across the country and Evan
different locations over the next three
weeks starting here in Manchester today
the students are back after their Easter
break it's starting to get a little bit
busy the whole point of this campaign a
no point of this road show is to
encourage people between the ages of 16
and 25 to get engaged in politics
perhaps they're not registered to vote
if they come here they can be helped to
register I think on it burning issue
that they want to get off their chests
this is the place they can come and do
it we've got a mobile studio here I just
stand over here this camera in front of
me is wired up to our headquarters in
central London that's being monitored
the whole time so if you're in
Manchester you've got something you want
to get off your chest today and you're
young come down to your stand on this
spot and just say your piece and
throughout the day we're going to be
monitoring the best little clips that we
get from this and because we put them
out and sky and you say so we can post
them on our social media pages on our
twitter feeds and on our website we've
also got this which is the sky knees be
counted touch screen camera now says
touch the screen to begin so I will
there it is and it's going to take my
photo here we are I'm holding up a
little placard and you get four of these
if you come down and for the Monroe
that's not the best shot I've ever had
taken ass we said but you can put a
message on here this message here says
you can make a chance you can make a
change even vote on May the seventh this
is what some of the young people who've
been here this morning already written
student media for democracy save our NHS
ready for Hillary I don't know if she's
a taking part and stand up we counted
yet it might be a little bit ambitious
there's also consoles here as I was
saying that they are linked to the
Electoral Register so if you are young
and you haven't registered to vote you
only have a week left to do it next
Monday is the cutoff date for
registering to vote but if you come down
here today in manchester on any of our
other locations throughout the next few
days you can go on the console and
that'll take you to the Electoral
Register website so you can register to
vote now some of the people who have
come down today I've got a bunch of
young people here how we're all involved
in politics in the manchester area in
different ways I thank you all very much
for coming down and being part of stand
at the counter will go through your warm
by 1 i'll start with you let from for
labor Andrea campus bigger'n out why did
you decide to get involved in
politics for one and why labor I've
always been quite political in the sense
that I've always had a really deep
feeling of social justice ingrained in
me and I think that from a young age
I've always been quite inclined with the
name party because it pushes values of
social equality and you know growing up
under a Blair government which saw
amazed which did amazing things
especially for single parents which one
over one single mother and for working
families and for our NHS and for
students I think that's something that
always name is putting a party from the
other that's why you got involved next
to you at the other side of the coin at
Jack Murray conservative why did you
decide to be motivated enough to get
involved and why was it the Conservative
Party that spoke to you as young
person's it's often not the young
person's traditional party it isn't but
it's changing conservative future is the
largest youth of all cuz the largest
youth party of any of the major protocol
parties and it's about what you see what
you want the country you live you want
to country that rewards people where
they work hard but people play by the
rules and get ahead and that's what the
Conservative Party offers and that's
what this election they're offering to
what was standing next to you Dominic
Hardwick and you're here as the voice of
the young lived ends now it's been a
hard sell I would imagine for you out on
the doorsteps at the moment because the
lib dems off it seems to be always now
linked with tuition fees and when we had
the big stand up you can to democracy
day where we had all the leaders it was
Nick Clegg hardest time about tuition
fees how is that for you well you might
find it surprising it's a number of
supporters that we do have in about the
area with young people one thing I've
noticed those is generally hard to sell
politics too
people because they don't really have
that much for voice when it comes to the
election over 360 seats and at the
moment won't change MP at the next
election because the safe and because
we've got a broken voting system young
people are turned off because their vote
won't change the outcome of the election
played in front of you Michael Wigram
now Michael yours new kit and when you
look at the demographic of the you kept
supporters they have a much older
demographic than all the other parties
that much smaller number of young people
involved what was it about them that
shouted out to you that made you think
you wanted to become involved then oh
well it's the scent on the evening I'm a
big supporter of direct democracy I
think every year and now it'll be
passing more and more power away to
Brussels to make more of our laws
without having any say for his people
you say about our older demographic but
then were the fastest growing youth
movement in politics at the moment we
have more than 3,500 young members I'm
29-27 societies up and down the country
at universities so we're growing rapidly
once a young people in politics well
next to you Catriona watson out now
you're with greens are they our party
which is traditionally had a very young
demographic voting for them is it a
party that you think you will always
vote for or a lot of people vote green
that's once in their life outside the
university and they only grow up but
they don't grow from them anymore how
are you gonna ensure that the young
people keep voting for the green car
gonna get over I think people when as we
get older the day become disillusioned
like Dominic said we have a broken boat
in system and a lot of people
see voting for greens is a wasted vote
no they don't necessarily agree with
Labour's policies but think are they're
going to win anyway so we might as well
vote for them and I suppose that's why
I'm in the Green Party because I think
and we do need to change our voting
system it was something that Tony wet
blood promised when he came in and then
decided that actually the current boats
and system work for him so didn't bother
changing it and but I think what people
need to remember is that voting for
Green still has an impact we've already
seen that Miliband adopts quite a few of
our policies as he sees he's losing
votes to the greens and so I think
people need to remember that it's not a
wasted vote and any vote for greens is
tell the politicians and the main
parties that people do support these
policies and they do they do agree with
green policies and not the kind of
austerity narrative of the three main
parties so when we talking about the
broken voting system that you get when
you're out and about campaigning what is
the reaction that you get from young
people in regard to politics so they
just feel that they haven't they haven't
got to say that they're not connected or
are you finding the people actually we
do have a view and they were you doing
the thing is people have a view but they
don't necessary necessarily see how
their view is related to politics so
they believe in rewarding work they
believe in why should you get something
for nothing but then when you translate
that to some of the political partisan
you know what yeah I do agree with that
and I think the main thing that all
political parties to have to do is try
and really make their message simple and
trying to track those voters because
there are people who support
conservative humane s not necessarily
believe they are conservators when you
explain the facts then they come around
and you know many of them join the party
and vote for the Conservatives Michael
foot for UK when you're out and about it
a lot has been made of the fact that you
give us the protest party are you
finding a lot of people who perhaps
haven't been engaged before and haven't
voted before or coming to you
because they feel that if a me sir most
definitely case we talk to people with
campaign trail a lot of people saying
that I'm not voted for anyone who last
20 years or in the last 10 years and
they want to
to vote for you kit because we're
speaking for their views an opinion
hasn't represented in our tapes for the
last 10 20 years and we are giving them
that Democratic choice Andrew when
you're right about what are the big
issues that people young people
particularly are concerned about in this
part of the world young people right now
are concerned about jobs when they leave
University and you know the Labour Party
saying we will guarantee a job forever
university but who hasn't got a job
within a year young people are worried
about their NHS being privatized and
sold off they're worried about the state
of services in the NHS and they're
worried about the economy in general and
you know you know they also care about
the future generation and they want the
party that will offer them and their
future generations a better plan and a
better future Dominic is not echoed by
you is that the same message that you're
hearing when you're around about the lib
dems the main message I'm hearing
Houston about the lib dems and when I'm
talking to young people like me is that
they people and concerned about the
opportunities that they're going to have
in life and concern about whether or not
they're going to be able to get a job
and concerned about whether or not that
jobs going to pay how much tax are going
to have to pay things like that people
are worried about the future naturally
Catriona in the frontier for the Greens
what do you think of the tone of the
campaign as it's been so
and I think there's been a lot of
rhetoric to be honest and I think a lot
of the lot of the main party leaders
kind of using these sort of flashy
phrases and I'm talking a lot but not
really saying much and like you know you
hit here in miller balancing a lot oh
yeah well I'm going to do something
about it and then it still doesn't
really have a clip on what actually is
going to do about it and think and a lot
of the promises david cameron's make
them dead Miliband apna promises to be
made by the main parties before and
never never delivered on you know and
Miliband talks a lot about oh yeah we
want to end zero-hours contracts for
them recently in the Welsh Assembly
voted against emotion to n zeros
contracts worth care workers so I think
the tone has been a lot of waffle to be
honest a lot of waffle there's also been
some mudslinging in the last week Jeff
do you think that's damaged the
Conservatives at all obviously not
because at the end the day no matter
what these other parties say choice'
this election is between labour of the
conservators and I think I think the
fact that Ed Miliband is not a strong
leader has been pointed out it's I mean
this is the person that's going to be
prime minister in charge of our armed
forces and I think it you know as an
opposition as a part of that supposing
them I think it's really important we
pointed out and let's be honest labor
aren't immune to you know singing some
mud when it suits them ok we're look 30
seconds left of us will very briefly not
necessary for your party but why should
young people vote have your voice heard
have a say in your future definitely yes
it's a democratic right the people fall
for user make you proud and have a say
the way your country's run
if you vote them people and politicians
will care about what you have to say and
more past policies that are good for you
decisions that made today will thank you
for the rest of your lives there get
involved an hour finally go through you
can people traditionally have very low
but voter turnout and light dom says if
you don't vote politicians will make
policies that cater for you so don't let
that happen again thank you all very
much well there you have it five people
you are very engaged with politics we
know there are a lot of you out there
who are very engaged in politics but
perhaps still have is registered to vote
perhaps feel like these contributors are
saying that your voices aren't being
heard by the main parties or by the main
leaders what can you do but you can
certainly register to vote you've only
got a week left to do it you can do it
here today at the stand up be counted
van here in the center of Manchester but
there's also lots of other ways you can
do it as well you can go online we're
going to have lots more coverage here
from Manchester and stand that we
counted throughout the day